[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
that's amelia hamlin getting emotional
when her boyfriend scott disick gifted
her a lavish birthday present
[Applause]
oh my god the model said goodbye to her
teenage years by celebrating in miami
florida and she shared the fun night on
instagram
and scott made sure his girl was iced
out for her milestone birthday
giving her a diamond cross necklace that
brought her to tears
and her new bling wasn't the only thing
sparkling that night
amelia wore a metallic gold crop top and
matching mini skirt
in an instagram post she showed off her
birthday suit and captioned the photo
the best birthday a girl could ask for
still more to come
the birthday girl was also showered with
tons of champagne bottles and a massive
cake covered in photos of amelia
including a nazi for work snap that
scott obviously enjoyed
last month amelia helped scott ring in
his 38th birthday by giving him a brand
new harley-davidson motorcycle
the motto also shared this sweet clip
cozying up to her man alongside the
caption
birthday cutie and posted a tribute on
insta writing you light up my life and
make my world better
i can't imagine what i would do without
you i'm so blessed to have met you
i love you that's great as for scott's
ex kourtney kardashian
well a source told e.t last month that
it's not weird for the reality star to
see your ex with another woman
but i'm not putting my energy there the
source says quote
courtney has been in her own world with
travis and they are so beyond obsessed
with each other
just like living life and whatever
happens happens